[Music]  i have spent my life trying to protect  my family  our battle begins today  [Music]  do you remember what it felt like  to live in peace  the world has changed  this new weapon more powerful than you  can imagine  it'll kill thousands  don't fight just death  my queen the travontians now can destroy  entire cities  hall of faire will be ours  we now have the greatest weapon this  world has ever known no religion will  stop it war is quite an elegant solution  i am your queen  my sister hunted us for 17 years and she  won't stop now i will die or allow  anything to happen to you  i never had to fight for my problem  now that crown will be forged in the  burning flames of war  i will be a queen reborn  you know in your heart what needs to be  done  hit them  again this moment  [Music]  [Music]  you